how does it feel when the fan tells you
that your music has saved their life Wow
I know exactly how it feels because me
in them and knowing them and connection
to them it saved mine oh yeah when a
musician reaches a certain point of
success they become accustomed to the
media rounds it certainly gets their
name out there but does it show you who
they really are
to get to the bottom of this we got
Youngblood Youngblood good a famous
musician with over 6 million monthly
listeners on Spotify alone and asked him
to sit down with strangers and fans
alike so that they could ask him
anything else going on I'm your board
I'm a musician and I'm here for you to
ask me anything yeah how are you it is
for real yes for real
should I get going with the question
yeah come on 100% ask me anything
what do people assume about you most
yeah I'm kind of a gobby brat that has
no idea what he's talking about
I think that's a big misconception for
one our generation and to the fanbase I
think people don't actually know that
we're completely in tune with what we
want an intelligent and thoughtful
matter what we want and we don't just go
like I'm gonna take the cars it's cool
no coffee real truth cereal first yeah
when it comes to songwriting I think
opening up is hard literally because she
actually - you have to put your heart on
a plate the people don't kiss it or stab
it with a knife what's the first thing
that you notice about your fans when you
meet them you're all well energetic so
we get quite shy but I just think like
if we're all very similar I was speaking
of someone yesterday and they were
talking to me about when they kind of
walk into a venue everyone feels like
they can just walk up to any random
person in that show and be like ello and
I'm a full blown conversation because
you're there and that made me really
happy and it kind of made me be like
yeah I wish I want onstage I wish I
could like
like la nice to meet ya yeah okay what
do you miss most about your life before
you're stuck in the house all day
playing live jumping about on stage just
raging yeah I only get to meet some
people right now that's what's kind of
cool about right now like I feel more
connected than ever to be honest I'm
speaking online all the time it's kind
of kind of amazing what was your
inspiration by your new song weird it
was about literature the weirdest time
my life ever imaginable which was weird
because now is the way this time ever
imaginable I was in this moment and
forgot all these things that happened in
my life and I was trying to hold on to
something that I thought was familiar
but then I realized I had to go through
the unfamiliar to grow up a bit more and
to learn how to control that feeling in
your stomach that when you falling down
avoid you not getting hurt you just got
to ride with it and you'll end up at a
destination that leads you a little bit
further in life do you remember what was
the big deal for you back to your point
for not starting out I started out and I
kind of came down London at 16 I moved
to the city because I needed to be
somewhere where he was like creative
people and then I was a kid and in
makeup and skirts like let's go I just
couldn't get signed to Columbia Records
I can't get anything and it was really
getting me down because people just
didn't like who I was and no one who are
playing empty rooms 210 people and then
we bought to show the Netherlands in a
hundred people turned up and they had
like hearts in the face and they had
t-shirts I met every single one of them
at the show and they must have put a
hundred pitch so nine hundred people did
that and one of the people saw that I
saw how crazy the show was was
interested in it spread spread spread
spread spread and here we are you know I
mean I think that showing in the
Netherlands was a real real big turning
point for me do you find yourself
wanting your parents approval of your
career or it's a self-acceptance you
found for yourself enough the self
acceptance of you find for yourself when
that happens is so powerful and so
liberate in that it doesn't matter who
doesn't want to love you for who you are
if you surround yourself with people who
do then everyone else doesn't matter
and no matter what emotional connection
got to them that was one thing
when I found EULA when I found all of
you I was like oh my god they get me
through who I'm supposed to be I'll call
these over it is these people understand
me these people get me these people
relate to me and then the day like music
is amazing bull is you guys who listen
to it and fly the flags
I'm scream it from the top of your lungs
that makes it a real thing
I started art again because your music
actually got me to start hard again oh
my god that's it so you're a huge
advocate for mental health and you know
I thank you for that friend a lot of my
heart how does it feel when the fan
tells you that your music has saved
their life Wow I know exactly how it
feels because me and them and knowing
them and connecting to them it saved
mine
Jami like oh yeah this whole thing
started because I was completely lost
and completely rock bottom and
completely sad all the time because I
couldn't be who I was I was never gonna
grow into the person I was gonna be
because the person I wanted to be was a
road that was blocked off until I found
you love it saves me to hear people go
and get you I understand so obviously in
kill somebody the dark takes you found
within yourself do you remember what it
was like first finding it I remember I
came down the first time and my best
friend James was live we've had like to
diagnose to rats
yeah and I remember telling him how I
was feeling all the time I wake up and I
felt like I've been punched in the
stomach she I don't open my eyes I could
I'd feel homeless for the first two
hours at well-core please I dude I think
you've got the pressure at the ego
anxiety and I was like what's that like
I never thought about that no feeling
hard and no no I felt what depression
and anxiety is it is a scary word to
hear at first so I just said I'm gonna
spend the rest of my life trying to make
people feel like if they have this
they're not abnormal and they're not
freaks and they're not different in a
bad way
yeah oh my god yesterday I was in a
really really really dark face and I
wasn't gonna make it alive like and I
got the email from Jubilee saying that I
could interview like right at the time
that I needed it the most
so I said well you love you themself
feel about hangout and please please
please just know that you love to know
this family loves you and accept you and
I here feel ok I'll see you next time
I'm in Ireland okay thank you love you
well it was amazing reading you know why
don't you simply say okay have a good
one thank you bye babe
thank you have a good one oh come on mum
thank you so much for having me I proper
log dot everyone don't forget to show
some love like comment and subscribe
weird just came out get that a listen
there's gonna be so many more young with
shows coming your way I can't wait for
you to see him
[Music]